there's a new Bill yes I'm only a bill
going around the Senate called the
Pelosi act I really love this bill this
was proposed by Senator Josh Hawley this
is a bill that he had previously
introduced so now he's retooled it a
little bit and renamed it it would uh
ban insider trading insider trading is
already banned but it would specifically
ban lawmakers and their spouses from
holding and trading individual stocks
and would force political figures to
return profits to the American citizens
and it is called the preventing elected
leaders from owning Securities and
Investments act I see what you did there
also known as the Pelosi Act and the
reason for this is that for whatever
reason Washington politicians have this
weird habit of outperforming the stock
market I tell you Joe they're on to it